et notre invité politique pour cette
émission spéciale région occitanie c'est
donc carole delga bonjour bonjour
inscrire beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes la présidente socialiste de cette
région que si la nuit on est ensemble
pendant une heure pour une interview en
partenariat avec la dépêche du midi midi
libre et l'indépendant est à mes côtés
pour cette interview eric berger bonjour
eric bonjour garneau avec nos rédacteurs
en chef adjoints la dépêche du midi
vincent coste journaliste à midi libre
bonjour bonjour et pierre mathis bonjour
pierre rédacteur en chef de
l'indépendant bonjour orioles on
commence bien sûr carole delga en
parlant de la crise sanitaire il ya un
an jour pour jour maintenant emmanuel
macron annonce est donc le premier
confinement est ce que ce jour a été un
tournant dans votre présidence de région
qu'est-ce qu'il a changé il ya changé
que nous devions vraiment donner
beaucoup plus de protection à la
population parce que il arrivait un
événement inédit dans l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est-à-dire une épidémie sur
l'ensemble de la planète et donc nous
devions être vraiment dans l'aspect
sanitaire beaucoup plus offensif et là
nous avons les présidents de région
décidé de commander des masques et bien
entendu d'enclencher des nouvelles
modalités d'accompagnement de la
population mais aussi des entreprises
donc c'est là où je pense les nouvelles
régions ont pris toute leur dimension
leurs dimensions bien sûr géographique
mais surtout en termes d'action c'est la
france dû faire c'est cela la
régionalisation et on va revenir sur ces
régionalisation mais on va rester sur la
situation sanitaire avec eric
justement est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'on est proche de la
sortie de cette crise du bout du bout du
tunnel d'un point de vue épidémique
on a l'impression que la région a quand
même un petit peu moins touchée
aujourd'hui que d'autres régions comme
les hauts de france où l'île de france
oui la région occitanie à des chiffres
encourageants mais pour autant j'appelle
voile et tous ceux qui écoutent cette
émission à respecter l'ensemble des
gestes barrières à être quand même très
très vigilants et la vaccination va nous
permettre de sortir de ce tunnel qui est
quand même très difficile à vivre pour
nos concitoyens qui a des graves
conséquences
conomique et social donc nous devons
être très vigilants nous devons
accélérer la vaccination et je pense que
l'année 2000 21 hrs permettra de
retrouver plus de liberté juste
précisions sur la situation sanitaire en
occitanie est ce qu'il ya des inégalités
entre les départements est ce qu'il ya
des zones qui vous inquiète
alors il ya des zones les zones urbaines
en effet des taux de propagation qui
sont plus élevés et c'est pourquoi il
faut toujours rappeler que le
rassemblement de personnes est assez
dangereux et nous devons continuer à
être très mobilisés nous accueillons des
patients d'autres régions parce qu'il
n'y a pas de tensions hospitalières en
occitanie mais nous devons toujours
faire des efforts et on va parler de
cette question et vincent justement lors
de au printemps dernier quand certaines
régions connaissait de fortes tensions
dans leurs oeufs dans leurs services
hospitaliers dans des publics ou privés
le
des établissements d'occitanie ont
accueilli des patients est ce que c'est
encore le cas est ce que c'est encore le
cas aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on sait combien de patients
étaient accueillis dans les
établissements d'occitanie de quelle
région
et est-ce qu'il y en aura d'autres
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres transferts qui
sont prévues dans les jours ou semaines
à venir et ce sont plusieurs dizaines de
patients qui sont venus de la région sud
paca qui ont été accueillis dans des
hôpitaux du gard de l'hérault des
pyrénées-orientales et cette semaine sur
le chu de toulouse
d'autres transferts sont prévues de 2,6
en régions la situation est toujours
préoccupante nous avons eu une capacité
d'accueil qui est très bonne ce qui
permet de limiter les déplacements
c'est la solidarité entre entre régions
et c'est indispensable
meoli signifie de pardon ce qui signifie
donc que les hôpitaux de la région ne
seront pas encore ne sont pas sous
tension non il n'y a pas de tension dans
les hôpitaux de la région
mais je tiens quand même à rappeler le
formidable travail des professionnels de
santé qui est vraiment à leur rendre
hommage parce que cela fait plus d'un an
qu'ils sont dans une situation
exceptionnelle et nous sommes très fiers
d'eux et nous savons ce que nous devons
à ces professionnels de santé juste pour
finir sur cette question des transferts
de patients olivier verront ailleurs il
disait qu'il ya plusieurs dizaines voire
plusieurs centaines de patients
d'ile-de-france qui sert évacuer vers
d'autres régions est ce que vous êtes en
lien avec valérie pécresse ou avec l'
ars d'ile-de-france dans le
l'ile-de-france va aller plutôt sur des
régions voisines
nous nous sommes plus un lien avec
l'auvergne rhône-alpes ou avec sud paca
donc pas d'accueil d'ile-de-france juste
pour finir sur ce qu'a dit olivier
verront ya pas de nouvelles mesures
coercitives annoncé malgré les chiffres
alarmants notamment dans trois régions
est ce que ça vous paraît risqué cette
stratégie ou est ce que vous dites c'est
la bonne stratégie il faut éviter à tout
prix leur confinement
je pense qu'il devrait y avoir une
différenciation territoriales ça a été
fait sur nice cet effet sur dunkerque
donc sur certaines département moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui les françaises et
les français peuvent tout à fait
comprendre que le niveau sanitaire étant
différent qu'il y ait des adaptations et
la question temple du couvre-feu à 18
heures dans certains départements je
pense qu'il n'est plus du tout
nécessaire et c'est pourquoi je demande
qu'il y ait une expérimentation dans les
départements dont les taux d'incidence
sont inférieures à semble
expérimentation bien sûr pour les lieux
culturels pour pouvoir commencer à
réouvrir avoir de nouveaux horizons
culturels mais aussi ample la pratique
sportive en extérieur donc
expérimentation vouliez mettre voudriez
mettre en place dans quel département
occitane occitanie on pourrait mettre ce
dans le gers dans le lot tous là où il
ya des taux d'incidence qui sont très
faibles
on va parler d'andorre avec la wii et de
la frontière en général c'est cette
crise est là elle a évoqué les
frontières elle a bloqué les échanges
justement une région aussi tadic et
transfrontalières et ses partenaires en
même temps il faut gérer des questions
de flux la l'andorre entend réguler rire
la plupart de ces la plupart de ses
services et de ses restaurants
aujourd'hui bon il y a des maires des
pyrénées orientales qui aujourd'hui
protestent contre la fermeture de la
frontière entre la france et l'espagne
puisque préfet installé des barrières
comment est-ce que vous au niveau de la
présidence de région pouvait intervenir
ou comment vous appréhendez ces
questions transfrontalières justement
ces questions transfrontalières c'est
vraiment essentiel par pour avoir une
réponse sur la différenciation
territoriales c'est ce que j'ai déjà
indiqué donc à jean castex sur la
question des stations de ski
nous avons un exemple terrible où il y
avait la possibilité de skier dans les
stations voisines espagnoles et ce
n'était pas le cas en france donc on
doit avoir beaucoup plus de souplesse
il ya 200 ans sur le premier confinement
il fallait avoir une mesure très forte
une mesure égalitaire parce que nous ne
connaissions pas du tout le virus était
plus le premier au mondial aujourd'hui
on a une expérience et donc on doit en
effet avoir un peu plus de souplesse et
dans les territoires qui sont
transfrontaliers qui ont des taux
d'incidence qui sont faibles à londres
vers l'expérimentation bien sûr sur les
lieux culturels sur les activités
sportives de plein air mais aussi par
exemple sur la question des restaurants
on peut avoir des tests c'est à dire il
faut mener une expérimentation sur le
terrain qui après servira pour
l'ensemble de la france
quand nous aurons la maîtrise de cette
épidémie
grâce à la vaccination et grâce à un
comportement responsable
justement
parler de la vaccination avec eric oui
le gouvernement parle d'une accélération
de la campagne de vaccination en france
on a quand même l'impression qu'on est
encore un peu en retard par rapport aux
autres pays vous sur le terrain qu'est
ce que vous constatez il ya une vraie
accélération dans dans la région alors
il y à une accélération ce week-end mais
sur le terrain force est de constater
qu'il y a encore aucun du mécontentement
parce qu'il est très difficile d'obtenir
des rendez-vous et la procédure
d'inscription sur une plateforme
numérique est assez complexe moi même
pour certaines de mes voisins à
martres-tolosane j'ai fait moi-même
l'inscription parce que cela était trop
compliqué pour des personnes âgées qui
ne maîtrise pas ce dispositif
donc il ya un peu un sentiment
d'exaspération sur la difficulté d'avoir
un rendez vous et ce week-end quand il
ya eu des vaccinations en accéléré il
n'avait pas pour autant le deuxième
rendez vous donc il faut avoir quand
même meilleure organisation je pense
qu'on a encore une marge de progression
ça veut dire qu'il ya encore des trous
dans la raquette sur 7 sur cette
question de l'accès nation qu'est ce que
la région un peu faire notamment vous le
dites pour les personnes âgées qui n'ont
pas forcément accès internet qui
n'arrivent pas forcément à prendre des
rendez vous alors là sur cette question
de l'inscription un des rendez-vous la
région n'a pas le droit d'intervenir
parce que le gouvernement a décidé que
c'était des inscriptions qui étaient
centralisées donc par cette plateforme
en revanche tout ce que nous faisons
c'est le transport gratuit
je les cistes de toutes les personnes
qui ont un rendez-vous de vaccination il
ya un numéro vert à la région et nous
allons chercher à domicile les personnes
qui ont des rendez-vous de vaccination
ils ne payent rien c'est vraiment à la
demande c'est du transport à la demande
et en plus nous travaillons bien sûr les
agences régionales de santé pour avoir
des camions qui vont permettre d'avoir
de la vaccination
c'est l'exemple d'un camion que la
région avec l'état financé sur de la
radiologie qui a été adapté ces
dernières semaines pour pouvoir faire de
la vaccination qui est basée dans les
hautes-pyrénées et nous réfléchissons
également avec le chu
toulouse avec les shelters les shelters
ce sont ces camions mobiles qui
permettent de répondre la médecine
d'urgence et pour qu'il puisse être
adapté sur la vaccination
là aussi on nous avait dit que de faire
des grandes banques cynodrome c'était
une mauvaise idée
il ya de ça deux mois moi je pensais
qu'il fallait le faire
heureusement que nous avons travaillé
avec les responsables de santé pour
préparer l'adaptation de ces camions
pour la vaccination
on l'a vu ça a été très utile sur le
week-end dernier en vigueur sur les
vaccinant drôme en occitanie combien où
il y aura un effet des bacs cynodrome
dans les prochaines semaines mais là
c'est au gouvernement qui a ce pouvoir
de décision sur cette question de la
vaccination les soignants sont réticents
à se faire soigner à ce que vous dites
une fois une vaccination obligatoire
pour ces soignants mois pour les
soigneurs je pense qu'un effet il faut
qu'il y ait une vaccination obligatoire
et j'incite à se faire vacciner
c'est absolument indispensable je trouve
d'ailleurs qu'il ya trop de précautions
qui ont été prises
le seul vaccin ou on demande un
consentement par écrit c'est le vaccin
contre la cofidis est quand même un peu
incroyable
il faut avoir une stratégie vaccinale
beaucoup plus offensive marsan il ya de
grands débats autour de la vaccination
la vaccination obligatoire vous venez
dit d'y répondre et également la
question du pass dupas sanitaires là
aussi est ce que vous y êtes obligataire
vous y être favorable notamment en
prévision de l'ouverture de la saison
touristique estivale
faut-il mettre en place un pass
sanitaire en place sur la vaccination je
pense qu elle doit être obligatoire pour
les soignants pour la population ça
serait un effet voilà tout à fait
inverse à ce qu'on veut donc il ne faut
pas avoir une réaction
l'association obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de population parce qu'on
sait qu'à ce moment-là ça cristallise
les oppositions et ça va être un sujet
de division suite concernant le
passeport vaccinale c'est différent le
passeport du passe temps que nous
n'avons pas un niveau de vaccination
supérieur c'est quand même très
difficile de mettre en place ce type de
dispositif mais à terme un effet sur la
fin de l'année c'est une stratégie qu'on
doit avoir à l'échelle européenne dans
les ehpad aujourd'hui
une majorité de résidents qui sont
vaccinées est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement doit alléger toutes les
contraintes de visite aux pensionnaires
dans les ehpad
oui nous avons en effet maintenant une
très bonne couverture des résidents des
maisons de retraite
et là je pense qu'un effet il faut
pouvoir rouvrir
parce que j'ai vécu à titre personnel
bien sûr la présence d'êtres chers dans
des maisons de retraite j'ai géré
moi-même une maison de retraite parce
qu'elle est municipal à martres tolosane
et on sait à quel point le lien la
proximité l'accompagnement est essentiel
pour nos aînés et donc on a besoin en
effet de pouvoir ré ouvrir nos maisons
de retraite pour qu'il sente l'affection
qu'ils puissent les maintenir vraiment
en bonne forme et envie oui vous parliez
tout à l'heure la de cette campagne de
d'accompagnement des gens qui veulent se
faire vacciner en milieu rural en fait
tout ça ça concerne essentiellement en
milieu rural comment est ce que est ce
que vous avez déjà des chiffres sur sur
la situation dans ses arrières pays où
c'est compliqué trouver des de se
déplacer pour certaines personnes et
comment est ce que vous jugez le rapport
d'efficacité que vous pouvez avoir vous
en tant que collectivité vocal avec
l'état sur la sueur sur l'organisation
de ces questions là qui sont très
concrètes qui concerne de très près les
citoyens et on voit que c'est souvent le
sait souvent l'on s'aperçoit que dans
l'eau du jeu vous soyez une grosse
campagne de grogne justement lié à cette
vaccination milieu rural c'est la région
qui a répondu vous savez comment ça se
passe concrètement pour justement aller
aller au plus près des gens et comment
ça se passe avec les services de l'état
surtout c'est vraiment une question
qu'on se pose alors pour aller au plus
près de leon peu près des gens mais il
faut proposer des solutions simples et
avoir de la réactivité à travers le
numéro vert sur le transport gratuit
pour la vaccination
cela fonctionne très bien en particulier
des territoires ruraux est le premier
département de l'occitanie qui en
bénéficient c'est le département des
pyrénées orientales
il faut en effet avoir plus de
décentralisation maintenant depuis
bientôt quatre ans ce pays a été re
centralisée
on a vu clairement que c'était un échec
et qu'on avait au niveau de la santé un
ministère qui était vraiment
complètement engorgé et des agences
régionales de santé qui n'avaient pas
assez de pouvoir qui n'ont pas de
pouvoir de décision
c'est pourquoi en matière de santé je
demande à ce que les régions puissent
agir de façon forte dans les
investissements dans les hôpitaux
bien sûr la santé reste une compétence
régalienne comme l'éducation
mais au même titre que les lycées les
régions pourraient financer des
investissements pour avoir des hôpitaux
locaux qu'ils soient bien équipés
c'est aussi les régions qui doivent
fixer le nombre de professionnels de
santé que ce soit pour les médecins que
ce soit pour les aides soignants que ce
soit pour les kinés pour l'ensemble des
professions de santé pour pouvoir
s'adapter aux réalités ont besoin parce
que sur la région occitanie qui est un
petit pays
eh bien nous avons des réalités de la
démographie médicale qui est tout à fait
différente
donc c'est à travers plus de
décentralisation que nous devons amener
un vrai service à la population des
vraies solutions
clairement avec les services de l'état
en région occitanie nous travaillons de
façon remarquable mais la
décentralisation ça dépend pas de
monsieur le préfet de région
ça dépend du président de la république
est là il faut avoir une toute autre
organisation en france ce sont les
régions qui sont la france dû faire de
l'action
c'est à travers les régions mais on doit
aussi par exemple sur la question du
handicap des personnes âgées donner plus
de pouvoir aux départements et bien
entendu les communes et les
intercommunalités doivent agir en
complémentarité
il faut donner plus de pouvoir aux
terrains et donc aux les collectivités
locales
et justement va continuer à parler de
ces questions de décentralisation avec
vincent
c'était une demande que vous répétez que
vous répétez fréquemment avant même le
début de cette crise vous vous et
métiers se veut de de plus de
décentralisation
ça doit être après la presle à présent
la présidentielle et les législatives de
2022 ça doit être un des grands
chantiers du
du prochain quinquennat vous parler de
la santé vous souhaiteriez d'autres
transferts de compétences pour tout ou
partie destinée aux régions notamment
maintenant nous avons des en france ces
grandes régions oui je pense que un pays
au 21ème siècle doit faire plus
confiance au terrain doit être vraiment
moins centralisée et doit s'adapter à
différentes réalités on a la maturité
politique la république une indivisible
elle est tout à fait compatible avec la
république des territoires ça fait des
années que j'ai écrit sur ce sujet et
dans chacune de mes fonctions c'est ce
que je mets en place c'est ce qu'on met
en place aussi au niveau de la région
occitanie la région elle ne fait pas
tout elle travaille en partenariat sur
la question temple des transports le
transport à la demande
c'est ce sont les intercommunalités qui
nous demandent les circuits et c'est la
région qui en financent 70%
il faut qu'au niveau en effet de l'état
il y ait une prise de conscience que la
décentralisation permet de recréer du
lien avec la population on a une crise
sanitaire on a aussi une crise
démocratique et la crise démocratique
elle aura comme réponse plus de
décentralisation plus de démocratie
participative au site de conscience de
l'état elle n'est pas là pour vous il ya
une l'encadré qui est sur la table quand
et par la ministre la culture au pourvoi
n'est pas à la hauteur cette lan cap des
7 le 24 e della beaucoup de manquements
par exemple sur la question des
professionnels de santé
le rôle des collectivités locales de
maintenant a été réduit il va il va
permettre cette loi 4 dès que les
régions puissent expérimenter
l'investissement hospitalier mais elle
ne veut ne va pas assez loin sur
d'autres sujets sur la question des
mobilités sur la question des transports
il y à une accumulation dans les zones
urbaines d'intervenants qui est
complètement ridicule quand vous êtes
sur une zone urbaine
vous avez
l'état qui est présent sur les routes
nationales vous avez ensuite les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
pour les avait après les départementales
et qui c'est qui doit faire rouler les
cars qui viennent des territoires ruraux
sur les territoires ruraux mais c'est la
région vous voyez vous avez quatre
intervenants du clairement vous le dites
juste être la cas de décès pas une vraie
loi de décentralisation
c'est 3,4 des elle ne va pas assez loin
et surtout ce que je dis c'est que nous
devons aussi avoir plus de souplesse sur
l'aide aux entreprises
c'est absolument indispensable pour
pouvoir créer de l'emploi on va en
parler des entreprises mais d'abord on
va parler de la crise sociale qui touche
particulièrement la jeunesse
oui parmi les victimes de la crise
sanitaire économique il y aller les
jeunes
on a beaucoup parlé des étudiants en
difficulté la précarité la difficulté de
trouver des stages est-ce que les
réponses du gouvernement sont sont à la
hauteur et qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire concrètement pour eux pour les
jeunes concrètement la première des
mesures c'était de faire en sorte que
l'ensemble plat de nos lycéens vendre
230 mille lycéens bénéficient tous de
l'ordinateur que nous avions distribué
gratuitement sur les 230 milles 6 5 il a
manqué juste 500 et donc on a distribué
à ces lycéens qui pour des raisons de ce
déménagement ne les avait pas vus on a
complété le dispositif avec 5000
ordinateur pour des étudiants qui
n'avaient pas les moyens de s'en acheter
et puis vous l'avez vu nous avons décidé
que pour la tranche d'âge des 18 26 ans
ça va être la gratuité du train c'est
absolument indispensable données sur les
pouvoirs d'achat
et puis une mesure à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup c'est sur la question de la
précarité
c'est à dire nous avons acheté les sur
plus de nos produits agricoles à nos
agriculteurs qui font des produits de
grande qualité et nous les avons
distribué aux associations d'aidé
alimentaire et un partenariat aussi avec
les crous donc il faut donner un avenir
à la jeunesse
il faut donner aussi je pense un revenu
nous avons une vraie problèmes de
précarité de 7,7 jeunesse et l'urgence
c'est certainement pas l'islamo
gauchisme dans les universités c'est
d'agir pour donner un espoir
un emploi est aussi une place complète
dans la société pour nos jeunes un rsa
pour les jeunes vous y est favorable
alors moi le terme rsa je pense qu'il
n'est pas adapté je pense que c'est une
allocation nous avons en europe
vraiment les droits sociaux qui sont
ouverts dès l'âge de 18 ans dans 24 pays
sur 27
la france n'ouvre pas les droits sociaux
à 18 ans donc il faut avoir cette
ouverture
il y a des présidents de départements en
occitanie ils sont très actifs sur ce
sujet qui demande une expérimentation
pour donner une allocation jeunesse je
pense que c'est absolument indispensable
parce qu'aujourd'hui un jeune quand ils
sortent des études où il peut
éventuellement avoir des bourses mais
pas toujours et bien et le moment où ils
recherchent à ce moment là un emploi il
n'a aucune rue aucune ressource
s'il n'a pas une famille derrière pour
l'aider il tombe dans une très très
grave
précarité il y avait un dispositif qui
avait été mis en place sous le
gouvernement
hollande qui a été supprimé en 2019 et
c'est dommage qui permettait une
allocation de 550 euros pour les jeunes
entre la fin des études est le premier
emploi moi je pense qu'on doit donner à
notre jeunesse
voilà un revenu de base comme le
demandent les présidents de départements
de gauche en france et je pense aussi
qu'il faut travailler sur la question
des stages mais des stages aussi à
l'étranger et nous vous en parlions ici
travaillons avec le maire de montpellier
sur ce sujet pour faire des propositions
parce que en effet en 2022 il y aura la
question de donner plus de pouvoir aux
territoires dire à la question de la
jeunesse et avec michaël delafosse nous
aurons des propositions à faire pour
permettre à cette jeunesse de découvrir
aussi le monde est de s'appuyer sur le
réseau diplomatique français qui est une
des meilleures au monde
on va parler de la crise économique
carole delga et particulièrement la
filière aéronautique avec éric maire oui
la région toulousaine et fortement
frappés par les conséquences de cette
crise et l'arrêt quasi complet du trafic
aérien qui a un gros impact sur
l'activité d'airbus des sous traitants
il ya des milliards d'euros qui ont été
débloqués la région a aussi fait
beaucoup mais est-ce que vous êtes
inquiète des prochains mois de ce qui va
se passer sur cette filière et notamment
pour tous les sous traitants qui
représente des milliers d'emplois oui je
suis très mobilisée pour l'ensemble de
la supply chain de l'aéronautique sur
tous les territoires agglomération
toulousaine mais attention
l'aéronautique elle irrigue l'ensemble
de la région
elle irrigue bien sûr les hautes
pyrénées bien sûr le lot l'aveyron avec
la mecanic vallée mais aussi elle a des
liens il faut le rappeler avec le gars
parce que nous avons de nombreuses
entreprises gardoises qui travaillent
pour l'aéronautique ou aussi autour de
béziers
donc la région nous avons mis en place
des aides bien sûr pour permettre la
diversification pour permettre la
recherche et l'innovation parce que dans
cette période
il faut que nos entreprises gardent la
compétitivité l' avance technologique
donc ils doivent continuer à investir
c'est aussi la diversification
nous avons permis à des entreprises
sous-traitantes de l'aéronautique
d'aller vers les énergies renouvelables
c'est à dire les flotteurs des éoliennes
flottantes au large de port-la-nouvelle
vont venir d'une entreprise
sous-traitante aéronautique qui est basé
dans le nord du lot matière et puis
surtout je voudrais rappeler que l'avion
c'est indispensable dans un débat où on
veut toujours stigmatisé l'avion ça
permet de relier les peuples alors bien
entendu on doit avoir une limite pour ne
prendre l'avion
quand il y à une offre de trains qui
permet de relier voilà en moins de 3h à
paris faut privilégier le train mais
pour autant l'avion il est indispensable
et dans cette société où on veut
toujours interdire je pense qu'au
contraire l'avion cet espace de liberté
et on doit développer l'avion décarbonée
c'est ce que fait airbus avec l'avion à
hydrogène et c'est ce que la région fait
également année dans les sous traitants
pour vraiment être sur sept avions plus
légers sur cet avion plus électrique
mais nous avons une politique globale
sur l'ensemble des transports c'est la
région occitanie qui a été la première
région
à commander des trains à hydrogène et là
la première en france pour
l'expérimentation d'écart à hydrogène
ça se fait à dans le tarn albi
l'entreprise safra et c'est la région
occitanie qui a passé une commande de 15
cars qui vont être une première en
france qui vont pouvoir faire de longues
distances avec l'hydrogène
grâce au savoir faire de nos entreprises
sur airbus une autre question le projet
d' usine de nouvelles usines
d'assemblage a été gelée est-ce que vous
avez des informations est ce que vous
pensez que ça reste toujours d'actualité
et que toulouse encore ses chances
d'obtenir cette cuisine j'en parle
régulièrement avec guillaume faury
airbus à une situation qui est quand
même très complexe les chiffres de 2000
veine montre vraiment de grosses de
cross perte pour autant pour autant je
sais que guillaume faury continue à
réfléchir ce projet n'est pas annulé
il est en suspens on peut tout à fait le
comprendre parce que la reprise du
trafic aérien s'est pas pour 2021 c'est
pour plus tard mais guillon fort hills
et qui a un écosystème à toulouse il ya
un environnement qui est très favorable
et donc sur cette chaîne d'assemblage
pour l'a321
nous continuons à travailler mais nous
sommes bien sûr sur une progression en
fonction de la reprise du trafic aérien
donc je fais plein de confiance à
guillaume faury pour prendre la bonne
décision dans le bon tempo
justement carole delga emmanuel macron
et à toulouse aujourd'hui pour le
premier exercice militaire spatial vous
allez évidemment allé le voir le chef de
l'état qu'est ce que vous allez lui
faire passer comme message
alors je vais lui faire passer comme
message qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
plus d'adaptation plus de liberté dans
des départements où le contexte
sanitaire est favorable je vais lui
demander d'avoir une zone de défense
puisqu'aujourd'hui en matière de
sécurité
la région occitanie ne dispose pas d'un
commandement propres nous dépendons soit
de bordeaux soit de marseille et sur
cette question de la sécurité il y a
besoin d'avoir une proximité de la
décision et puis je vais aussi lui
parler de l'emploi
d'abord l'entreprise bosch l'entreprise
de sam toutes les deux ânes à vérone et
également pour soutenir l'emploi
les petites lignes ferroviaires lui
demander qu'il accélère sur le transfert
des lignes montréjeau luchon et des
ligne alès bessèges pour permettre ces
travaux et bien entendu la question des
lgv bordeaux toulouse on va reparler on
va parler de ces questions de transport
dans votre région mais un mot sur bosch
puisque vous en parliez 1 c'est moche
c'est l'usiné rodez den bosch dans
l'aveyron qui va supprimer 750 emplois
d'ici 2025
qu'est ce que vous allez dire au chef de
l'état que l'état intervienne mais
qu'est ce qu'il peut faire
mais l'état doit avoir un partenariat
avec bausch pour permettre une
diversification qui soit réelle et que
le groupe bosch là est une vraie
politique d'accompagnement pour des
départs en pré retraite et une vraie
politique de formation pour aller vers
les nouvelles technologies de
motorisation pour aller réellement vers
l'hydrogène
donc c'est ce message que je ferai
passer au président de république mais
aussi pour l'entreprise sam
parce que le plan qui est présenté par
le potentiel repreneur n'est pas assez
finalisé il y a trop de suppression
d'emplois est trop de zones d'ombrés
encore dans cette offre moi je pense à
ces salariés qui ont un savoir faire
exceptionnel qui ont beaucoup de
responsabilités et aujourd'hui les
réponses par ces grands groupes
industriels ne sont pas à la auteur on
va parler des stations de ski maintenant
avec pierre mathis et oui parce que
c'est un les autres unes des autres
conséquences économiques de la crise
sanitaire
vous êtes beaucoup battu pour être
tentés de l'est
de les garder ouverte au mois de sauver
les vacances peut-être de février bon
c'est pas comme ça que ça s'est passé la
catastrophe est née elle est réalisée
pour les stations de ski et puis au delà
pour toute l'économie de la montagne
comment comptez vous justement
accompagner les mois qui viennent
l'année qui viennent qui va certainement
être être décisif parce qu'on sait très
bien que c'était déjà une économie un
petit peu fragile en tout cas les
remontées mécaniques et que de toute
manière il faut relancer la totalité
d'un secteur qui s'étend sur trois
départements de la région qui concerne
la totalité de la chaîne canadienne
nous avons la montagne l'occitanie bien
sûr ce sont les pyrénées mais il faut
pas oublier aussi le massif central puis
sur cette question de la transition du
modèle économique des stations de
montagne nous l'avions anticipé
c'est notre pacte vers le green new deal
donc très concrètement la région a créé
une compagnie de compagnie des pyrénées
pour pouvoir investir pour pouvoir
investir dans le tourisme quatre saisons
pour pouvoir investir aussi sur les
domaines skiables pouvoir aussi investir
sur la question de l'hébergement et de
pouvoir aussi travaillé sur
l'exploitation et une mutualisation
donc nous avons malheureusement eu à
faire cette fermeture des stations de
ski et ça n'a fait qu'accélérer cette
transition du modèle économique
donc là à travers la compagnie des
pyrénées la banque des territoires la
caisse des dépôts c'est à dire nous
accompagne avec la région les
départements
l'ensemble des stations et là nous avons
un vrai outil qui permet d'amener des
subventions qui permet d'amener des
garanties financières et qui permet
aussi d'amener une expertise donc là
nous avons des projets avec plusieurs
stations de montagne qui permettront de
remonter la pente mais il ne faut pas se
le cacher la situation financière est
très préoccupante parce que c'est 250
millions de
chiffre d'affaires qui n'ont pas été
faits sur ses stations
donc nous allons bien sûr développer le
tourisme quatre saisons mais nous avons
toujours bien sûr la question du ski sur
les stations de holt attitude que nous
soutiendrons et puis développé aussi
tout ce qui est thermalisme bien-être ça
c'est vraiment notre adn en occitanie
c'est cette montagne qui est authentique
qui est quand même très préservé qui est
à échelle d'hommes et de femmes et nous
allons pouvoir développer une offre une
offre sportive bien sûr de toutes les
saisons mais aussi une offre qui met en
valeur la qualité de vie le
thermoludisme le thermalisme et après
tout la question des de la culture de la
montagne que ce soit les pyrénées ou de
l'asie centrale
vous parliez du pacte vert on va en
parler avec vincent coste lors de votre
mandature donc vous avez été l'occitanie
et est la première région lancé un pacte
vert inspiré un peu du green new deal
européenne
l'idée étant que les questions de
protection de l'environnement de
développement durable irrigue tous les
budgets tous les financements toutes les
politiques tous les projets de la région
en cette période de grave crise
économique et qui risquent de de
perdurer ses très hautes ambitions sont
elles toujours tenable le pacte vert
va-t-il être reconfigurer ou continuer
vous sur la sur la lancée sur ce que
vous avez initié avant même que cette
crise ne frappe le pacte vert a en effet
été élaborée avant la crise sanitaire
mais le pacte vert c'est la bonne
réponse c'est à dire que la transition
écologique énergétique c'est un des axes
à privilégier pour pouvoir bâtir nouveau
modèle de développement
le pacte vers le green new deal c'est la
solution à la crise que nous vivons
crise sanitaire crise économique crise
sociale crise climatique nous la vivons
depuis des années mais aussi crise
démocratique
le pacte vert c'est concilier pour être
très clair économie et écologie
c'est la création d'emplois à travers la
rénovation énergie
kiko nous avons vraiment la capacité de
créer des emplois de façon très très
forte plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'emplois sur la rénovation des
logements
cela permet d'avoir des factures
d'énergie qui sont moins élevés donc
c'est bon pour le pouvoir d'achat
ça fait du travail pour nos artisans
pour toutes nos entreprises du bâtiment
et c'est bon bien sûr sur l'impact
environnemental parce que ce qui est
important c'est déjà de consommer moins
d'énergie la question des énergies
renouvelables là ça crée de l'emploi
heureusement que nous avions voté il ya
de ça maintenant deux ans et demi un
plein d'hydrogène
nous avons été la première région de
france a voté le plan d'hydrogel est
aujourd'hui l'hydrogène permet d'avoir
de la création d'emplois je l'indiquais
à travers une entreprise la safra qui
est basée à albi mais aussi par exemple
pour l'entreprise cameron qui est basée
à béziers où nous avons créé avec la
filiale de chaume berger une société la
région est actionnaire pour la
production d'électrolyseurs d'hydrogène
vert donc c'est la bonne réponse le
pacte vert mais le pacte vert aussi
c'est sur l'alimentation
je le rappelle un secteur en occitanie
économique qui se porte très bien
c'est l'agroalimentaire on a une
agriculture de la qualité une
agriculture familiale et là nous allons
continuer à promouvoir l'histoire cuit
cours à faire en sorte que les habitants
de l'occitanie et continue à manger les
bons produits
c'est l'exemple de ce que nous avons
fait avec dans ma zone avec les
plateformes de produits alimentaires ou
les plateformes pour acheter locaux vous
voulez acheter un jean un vélo fait en
occitanie c'est possible c'est ce que
nous mettons en oeuvre
donc ce pacte vert c'est en fait la
valorisation de nos ressources
naturelles
c'est la création de valeur ajoutée sur
place et donc c'est la création
d'emplois donc le pacte vert c'est la
bonne solution
moi je crois beaucoup à cette question
de la conciliation la transition
écologique
c'est la solution il ne faut pas être
dans des positions dogmatiques ou dans
des positions intégristes à travers cet
accompagnement à travers ce
fédération autour de l'écologie on va
créer des emplois et même l'industrie
est vraiment partie prenante
c'est ce que nous avons fait en
occitanie c'est à dire nous avons joué
collectif juste qu'il ya des positions
dogmatiques l'intériste moi j'entends
qu'il y a sûrement sur cette question
écologique
voilà des grandes orgues en disant qu'il
ne faut plus manger de viande qu'il ne
faut plus prendre l'avion
la viande oui fond de magie il faut
manger de la viande d'occitanie parce
que c'est ça la vraie problématique
quand on dit que manger de la viande
c'est mauvais pour l'environnement
c'est inexact c'est qu'on mange de la
viande qui viennent de l'autre bout du
monde
en effet le bilan carbone carbone est
catastrophique mais quand on mange de la
viande oeufs d'occitanie c'est bon pour
la planète parce que à travers l'élevage
ce sont des terres qui sont pas kg et le
meilleur puits à carbone au point de vue
scientifique ce sont les terres qui sont
partagées par kg par les bêtes donc
mangeons de la viande d'occitanie vous
allez pouvoir me donner comme argument
ça coûte plus cher la viande d'occitanie
que de la viande qui va venir d'amérique
du sud
mais les meilleurs donc pour le même
budget il vaut mieux acheter moins de
viande mais devient de d'occitanie qui a
de meilleures qualités nutritives et qui
permet de concilier alimentation et
santé donc ça veut dire que les élus
locaux verts notamment grégory tous les
ans qui après cette décision deux menus
sans viande et ont des positions
dogmatiques pour vous moi je pense que
ce sont des positions qui sont trop
dogmatique et dans un politique et tout
particulièrement la politique au sens
premier du terme la gestion de la cité
et tout particulièrement dans notre
période de crise il faut être dans l'
équilibre
alors je dis oui à des menus végétariens
mais le lendemain il ya menu avait
viande et le surlendemain et à menu avec
poisson c'est cela qu'attendent nos
concitoyens des solutions de l'
équilibre et surtout de rassembler et de
ne pas diviser
hamon pierre sur l'éolien marin oui mais
justement c'est on est en plein dedans
c'est assez paradoxal de voir qu'un
projet du commun comme les éoliennes qui
se présente pour de l'énergie nouvelle
essentiellement un contesté par des
associations lors d'un point de vue
local voire par des élus
ben pour son impact environnemental
puisque séoul yens qu'ils doivent être
implantées au large de port la nouvelle
le cadre du barcarès donc il remettra en
cause et puis il pointe aussi le coût de
cette expérience qui est très nouvelle
comment est ce que vous êtes toujours ce
que vous aurez toujours les capacités
d'investissement justement à la suite de
la crise pour pour un tel projet comment
vous évaluez aujourd'hui ce projet qu'il
ya une très donateurs ne serait ce que
deux je pense que quand les éoliennes
vont commencer à s'élever ont beaucoup
en parler alors sur l'aspect
acceptabilité de l'éolien flottant
nous avons la chance d'avoir le
parlement de la mer qu'avait créé
christian bourquin que didier codorniou
président et qui permet d'avoir une
concertation
donc ce projet les portées par
l'ensemble des acteurs de la mer que ça
soit les pêcheurs que ça soit l'ensemble
des élus donc on a un vrai consensus
la question de l'éolien flottant il est
fondamental pour la question de la
transition énergétique à travers le
projet dit de port la nouvelle
c'est 40 % de production de l'énergie
renouvelable éolienne de notre région
donc c'est majeur si on veut de
l'hydrogène vert parce que c'est de
l'hydrogène de verre qu'il faut produire
il faut bien avoir de l'électricité à
partir de l'éolien flottant
il y aura d'autres possibilités à
travers pendant que l'hydroélectricité à
travers la méthanisation
mais là on a un projet qui est
fantastique qui nous permettra d'avoir
volume de production d'énergie verte
significatif
rien que avec le projet expérimental qui
de l'éolien flottant de port-la-nouvelle
c'est l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique d'une ville comme narbonne
ensuite à travers ce projet nous allons
donc avoir des transformations sur
l'énergie un groupe comme chez mme
berger si il crée une société sur
l'occitanie d'un suspect dans ce
dispositif là c'est parce que cette
filière elle a un avenir
donc ce n'est pas une lubie de carole
delga de l'éolien flottant
tout d'abord il y a projet européenne
sur cette question de léo
photo et surtout il ya des investisseurs
donc là ce projet est indispensable pour
la nouvelle c'est le port de la
transition énergétique et nous avons
besoin d'investir nous en avons les
capacités parce que la région est bien
gérer parce qu'elle a une forte capacité
d'investissement nous faisons partie des
régions les moins endettées de france et
surtout cet investissement parce que la
dépense publique il faut en parler
la dépense publique elle est salutaire
quand l'économie est en difficulté et
quand les régions investissent pour
créer de l'emploi à travers la
transition énergétique on crée de
l'emploi l'entreprise matière elle va
avoir des marchés et donc de l'emploi
parce qu'elle va fabriquer les et les
flotteurs des éoliennes flottantes
c'est à dire les lotois qui vont avoir
du job grâce à ces éoliennes qui en
termes d'impact visuel représenteront la
taille d'une allumette puisqu'elles sont
très au large de la méditerranée
on va parler transport et lgv avec eric
oui en effet je crois que c'est un sujet
que vous avez évoqué avec le président
de la république tout à l'heure c'est un
nouveau dossier phare que vous que vous
portez c'est ce projet de lgv de ligne à
grande vitesse entre bordeaux et
toulouse dont on entend parler depuis
des années pour pas dire des décennies
qui est fortement attendue vous aviez
fixé un espoir en horizon 2030
est-ce que c'est tenable est-ce que ce
dossier ce projet va enfin vraiment
avancer dans des phases un peu plus con
4 concrètes alors c'est un projet qui
avaient bien avancé mais qui a été
complètement stoppée à partir de juillet
2010 est donc voilà nous avons perdu
plus de plus de 3 ans depuis septembre à
2020 depuis que jean castex a été nommé
premier ministre il recommence à avoir
vraiment une avancée mais je continuerai
bien sûr à défendre et ce matin au
président de la république je vais lui
rappeler qu'il est nécessaire pour le
financement de cette lgv de commencer à
créer une société de financement qui
sera entre agen et toulouse
parce que le secteur ne plus saturée de
cette future lgv c'est entre toulouse et
montauban aujourd'hui saturation
complète
je ne peux pas répondre à la demande de
mes habitants qui veulent plus de trains
sur le tarn et garonne et d'ici quatre
ans la ligne et les statures et jusqu'à
j'aime donc on a besoin d'avoir une
deuxième ligne
si on veut faire le rer métropolitaine
il ya besoin de cette deuxième ligne
c'est cela la réalité est bien entendu
je vais lui parler aussi de la lgv
montpellier perpignan tu avec la
première tranche c'est-à-dire
montpellier béziers
mais c'est un petit peu le paradoxe à
votre situation vous avez deux chaînons
manquants en fait vous en avez un autre
bordeaux à toulouse et vous en avez un
autre entre perpignan et montpellier
jean castex nous a assuré que dix ans en
2021 il arriverait ainsi l'état décisive
sur le tronçon montpellier béziers pour
par la création d'une dune d'une société
d'investissement alors tout ça est
conditionnel ou à mobilité et c'est ce
que vous partagez son optimiste vous
pensez qu'en 2021 cette avancée wire
petit mais indispensable va pouvoir se
produire pouvoir quand même dans quel
inégalités des habitants de l'occitanie
sont par rapport aux autres françaises
et français par un chiffre sur
l'ensemble de la population française
qui a plus de quatre heures de paris par
le train
60 % sont des habitants de l'occitanie
c'est à dire ce sont soit des occitans
soit des catalogues 60%
voilà cette région elle a été oubliée du
train à grande vitesse de pouvoir être
connecté rapidement à paris et à
bruxelles
c'est une vraie injustice et je me bats
contre cette injustice et sur la lgv
montpellier perpignan ce qu'il faut
avoir en 2021
celle enquête publique pour le premier
la première phrase qui est montpellier
béziers et nous y travaillons en
concertation avec un effet les services
de matignon je le confirme ce qu'on a vu
l'arrivée de jean castex est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour pour en tout cas vos
objectifs parce que
il ya un premier ministre qui semble un
petit peu plus intéressés par la grande
vitesse que ses prédécesseurs jean
castex est vraiment passionné par la
question du rail
vous le savez et j'ai l'objectivité de
dire les vérités
donc ce projet du train en france de
façon globale a été complètement bloquée
de juillet 2010 2017
jusqu'à l'été 2020 le nouveau premier
ministre souhaite avoir un partenariat
avec le président de la sncf une
politique beaucoup plus volontariste sur
la lgv mais si on réussit les petites
lignes d'aménagement du territoire
parce que le train en france il doit
servir bien sûr au transport de masse à
la grande vitesse mais il doit aussi
relier les territoires moi je veux du
train qui soit en fait une irrigation de
l'ensemble des territoires
je pense à de grandes lignes l'aubrac où
le cévenol
mais je pense aussi à ces lignes que la
région va réouvrir va financer
intégralement ses montréjeau luchon et
c'est alès bessèges et aussi sur la rive
droite du rhône nous nous y travaillons
et puis nous avons d'autres projets
encore sur d'autres territoires
avant de parler des régionales on va
faire une question sur la région
occitanie avec vincent oui puisque les
régionales finalement vont marquer aussi
l'occasion de faire un premier bilan de
cette première mandature dans ces
grandes régions avec six ans de recul
en ce qui concerne l'occitanie quel est
votre bilan sur cette grande région sur
sa pertinence sur sa cohérence sur elle
fonctionne elle est trop grande elle et
elle aurait dû être dimensionnée
différemment quel est votre quel est
votre regard où justement on regarde
votre expérience de 6 ans la tête de
cette nouvelle région c'est moi je suis
quelqu'un de très cohérent j'ai toujours
défendu les grandes régions aussi bien
quand j'étais vice présidente de martin
malvy que comme j'étais au gouvernement
alors pourquoi j'ai défendu les grandes
régions et pourquoi je souhaitais que
midi-pyrénées s'associe à languedoc
roussillon parce que tout d'abord ça
correspond un périmètre historique faut
quand même leur rappeler à travers les
états du languedoc
nous avons grosso modo le périmètre de
la région occitanie et ça c'est
essentiel pour que un territoire puisse
fonctionner il faut qu'il y ait une
histoire commune et nous avons cette
histoire commune qui a été construite à
travers les siècles
toulouse et montpellier étaient déjà les
deux capitales des états du languedoc et
même si on va plus loin au niveau de la
romanité cette région elle existait donc
là il y a une vraie identité culturelle
on a un vrai substrat comme un
historique
et puis ces grandes régions je les ai
toujours défendu parce qu'elles
permettent d'avoir de réels résultats en
matière économique en matière d'emploi
la région occitanistes et la force et la
proximité c'est la force parce que comme
je l'indiquais pendent sur la filière de
l'hydrogène nous pouvons avoir du début
à la fin
une cohérence d'action sur la production
d'hydrogène sur la distribution sur les
usages ça soit pour le train soit pour
eux aussi les véhicules individuels ou
que ce soit pour les bus sur la question
de l'agroalimentaire nous avons aussi la
force de présenter sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne une production une transformation
une création d'emplois sur la
viticulture nous sommes la plus grande
région au monde pour les vins de qualité
là quand nous sommes à l'international
nous pesons quand nous allons dans des
grandes salles ont même s'ils sont
virtuels on a une gamme de produits de
vin qui est exceptionnel et puis c'est
la proximité parce que j'ai voulu qu'il
y ait des maisons de la région et c'est
à dire que nous nous adaptons aux
réalités des territoires et l'échelle
régionale
c'est la bonne échelle et donc je pense
que l'occitanie c'est une région que ses
habitants ont au coeur et qui a une
bonne reconnaissance et on va parler des
régionales 40 des gains avec une
première question d'énergie oui tout
d'abord est ce que vous pensez que ces
élections vont vraiment se tenir au mois
de juin
décision définitive doit être prise au
mois d'avril en fonction de la situation
sanitaire à ce qu'un report et vous
semble pertinent et est envisageable
donc tout d'abord je rappelle que dans
d'autres pays qui avaient des situations
sanitaires aux gamins plus compliquée
que celle de la france des élections ont
été organisées et il cela n'a pas
provoqué de flambée de l'épidémie
ensuite on va paraître en juin on vous
cela doit être en juin ça doit être un
juin sauf événement exceptionnel
et puis on peut pas continuer à confiner
la démocratie parce que sinon en 2022 ça
veut dire qu'il y aura quatre élections
en 2022 il y aura la présidentielle les
législatives les départementales et
régionales
alors quand on me dit que les gens ne
vont pas aller à voter en juin
imaginez vous une année que va y avoir
quatre élections quelle va être la
mobilisation les gens vont en avoir ras
le bol il y aurait quand même la
possibilité de les organiser en
septembre après ça serait impossible
mais oui j'aimerais une fenêtre en
septembre ça peut être en septembre mais
je pense que avec en plus les
adaptations qui ont été permises par la
loi c'est à dire d'avoir des tranches
horaires plus larges c'est à dire
d'avoir deux procurations par personne
d'augmenter le nombre de bureaux de vote
je le dis aux habitants de l'occitanie
aux françaises et français
ces élections peuvent être organisées en
toute sécurité en juin alors pour ce
scrutin alors que vous aviez une
majorité assez large à gauche avec en
particulier des les écologistes
finalement le choix a été fait des
écologistes d'investir antoine maurice
tu maurice est de partir de manière
autonome
il ya donc deux listes la vôtre et celle
des écologistes
quelle quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à ça et ce qui est encore
possible comme dans les hauts de france
tout récemment qu'un accord soit trouvé
avant le premier tour et finalement vous
fassiez liste liste commune
alors mon équipe l'occitanie en commun
tout d'abord comporte des écologistes et
je vous rappelle que la moitié des
conseillers régionaux écologistes
continuent à travailler avec moi et donc
partent vraiment dans
dans mon lit quand même cette liste
europe écologie les verts est ce que
vous êtes en discussion avec antoine
maurice est ce qu'un accord est possible
ou pas cela fait un an que je tends la
main aux écologistes et je continue à
leur dire nous avons bien travaillé
ensemble
mon projet il est écologiste mais
concrètement vous discutez avec lui où
vous lui tendez la main par mais je lis
je l'y ai écrit vous le savez il m'a
répondu par la négative mais aujourd'hui
je continue à lui tendre la main à lui
dire travaillons ensemble on a passé
cinq ans ou franchement on a eu vraiment
des solutions qui ont été amenées on a
agi on n'a pas été dans le blabla on a
été dans l'écologie dû faire et moi
j'aime projet écologiste et dans ma
liste
il y a des écologistes soyons sur
l'union de la gauche de la gauche
réformiste est de la gauche écologiste
on va continuer évidemment parler de
cette élection va regarder ce sondage
ifop 1 pour les républicains vous est
donné en tête à 28% et juste derrière
vous c'est jean paul garraud le candidat
du rassemblement national qui est à 26 %
les autres candidats sont plus loin
derrière c'est aurélien pradié pour les
républicains qui arrivent troisièmes à
13% est ce que le fait d'être talonner
comme sa part le rassemblement national
ça vous inquiète tout d'abord un sondage
voilà c'est il faut toujours avoir
beaucoup de recul sur cela il faut faire
voilà des vraies peaux des propositions
d'avoir un vrai projet oui la question
de l'extrême droite le préoccupe et delà
de son score élevé en occitanie
malheureusement certainement dans
d'autres dans d'autres régions
voilà pour moi c'est oui c'est que c'est
une vraie inquiétude parce que je suis
très attaché à la république française à
sa devise républicaine liberté égalité
fraternité et pourrions sa république un
rassemblement national dont le
rassemblement national n'est pas
républicain parce qu'ils ne respectent
pas la devise la devise française c'est
liberté égalité fraternité
nous le savons toutes et tous les idées
d'extrême droite les idées du
rassemblement national ce sont des idées
racistes xénophobes
c'est la haine de l'autre c'est la
volonté de créer une société d'ennemis
et donc bien sûr je ne souhaite pas que
l'extrême droite soit élevé dans mon
pays et je la combat et je ferai en
sorte bien
entendu qu'une fois de plus l'extrême
droite perde que nous puissions gagner
un mot juste sur jean paul garraud hier
marine le pen sur bfm tv a dit que si
elle était élue à la présidence de la
république elle en ferait son ministre
de la justice est ce que ça en fait un
adversaire plus redoutable pour vous non
non moi je préférais quelle que soit la
personnalité
ce que je vois c'est les idées et
derrière voilà les hommes et les femmes
ont peu d'importance
ce qui est quand même gravissime ce sont
les idées de l'extrême droite
je me permet quand même de rappeler que
la france a toujours combattu les idées
d'extrême droite et nous avons quand
même une république et une vision qui a
fait en sorte que nous avons gagné face
au fascisme au nazisme mais justement il
n'empêche qu'avec jean paul garraud ce
qui vient de triompher c'est un petit
peu la ligne a lieu au niveau régional
c'est à dire une stratégie dite de
dédiabolisation voir à perpignan de
notabilisation ce sera peut-être un
adversaire plus difficiles à identifier
que certains autres parce que certains
autres personnalités du rassemblement
national ici en occitanie puisque il va
se présenter de manière très neutre très
très vite et un petit peu le combat le
combat frontal en plus que vous veniez
de dire est ce que ça vous oblige pas un
petit peu adapter votre discours par
rapport à un rassemblement national ou
pas est-ce que comment comment vous
comptez vous inviter à sa la stratégie
de l'extrême droite et donc de madame le
pen s'est en effet d'avoir une
cosmétique qui soit beaucoup plus
présentable et jean paul garraud ancien
député elle l'air peut donner
l'apparence
je dis bien l'apparence d'une un peu
plus de rondeur du voilà d'une apparence
un peu mais les idées sont là quand vous
lisez les propos
de monsieur garraud voilà sur la
question de l'insécurité
il indique que président de région il va
créer une police des transports
j'ai mangé du début à la fin les
présidents de régions en france n'ont
pas de pouvoir de police qui sait quels
pouvoirs de police dans un pays comme la
france c'est l'état et après ce sont les
maires et ça s'arrête là donc faut
arrêter de mentir parce que ça aussi
c'est de l'idéologie c'est vraiment
vraiment de l'endoctrinement donc
monsieur gars on connaît ses idées vous
savez sur la question des élus d'extrême
droite
regardez ce que vient de faire monsieur
à lyon monsieur à lyon réécrit
l'histoire par rapport à la guerre
d'algérie
donc on ne peut pas quand même accepter
d'avoir une telle déformation monsieur
ménard ski matiz et les enfants dans les
écoles en fonction de la consonance de
leur prénom
donc on sait ce qu'il y a derrière cette
apparence de notabilisation l'extrême
droite est dangereuse pour le france et
je le dis à vos téléspectateurs
moi je ne peux pas accepter comme en
pays qui est la patrie des droits de
l'homme
mon pays où il ya des hommes qui sont
morts et qui donne les noms sur les
monuments aux morts
et bien cette mémoire elle doit être
honorée et donc on doit être digne
on doit combattre les idées d'extrême
droite peu importe
l'apparence peu importe le beau costume
ce qu'il faut c'est avoir une france qui
soit fraternelle qui tentent de la même
aux autres et surtout qu'il n'y ait pas
de discrimination qu'il n'y ait pas de
racisme
la france elle est grande quand elle est
conforme aux valeurs de la résistance
c'est ça que nous devons avoir en tête
et dernière question de façon justement
sur ce thème là le débat la semaine
dernière à tourner dès des voix à gauche
se sont se sont élevées de la part de
responsables politiques ou des lecteurs
pour dire que dans l'hypothèse d'un
second tour de la présidentielle entre
emmanuel macron emma marine le pen en
contrairement à ce que certains ont pu
faire en cinq ans auparavant ils
n'iraient pas voter pour emmanuel macron
il n'irait pas voter
simplement il s'abstiendrait comment
vous positionnez vous faites dans ce cas
de figure précis au cas où il y ait un
ce ce duel au second tour de la
présidentielle de 2000 22 que les choses
soient bien claires je ne souhaite pas
qu'ils aient ce duel parce que ce duel
et mortifère emmanuel macron contre
marine le pen
mais si ce duel là était le soir du
premier tour
je serai la première à appeler à voter
emmanuel macron comme je lé fais bien
sûr il y a de cela 5 ans vraiment c'est
absolument indispensable pour autant il
y à une réalité et celles et ceux qui ne
veulent pas la voir son inconscient il
ya une réalité dans ce pays c'est que
l'appel que je pourrais faire et bien je
sais qu'il aura peu de chances d'être
suivi parce que aujourd'hui il ya un
sentiment de trahison de la part du
peuple de gauche par rapport à emmanuel
macron est alors en effet quand
libération
votre
[Musique]